y
[Música]
aumenta la escalada de tensión entre
azerbaiyán y armenia en europa oriental
por el control del territorio nagorno
karabaj en un enclave separatista
fronterizo en donde este domingo se han
registrado graves incidentes militares
rusia llama a un alto al fuego inmediato
la fuerza conservadora amy cón iba a ver
es la nominada del presidente de eeuu
donald trump a la corte suprema en
reemplazo de ruth báder ginsburg la
nominación se da pocas semanas ante las
elecciones presidenciales de los
demócratas afirman que se debe elegir
este reemplazo después de los comicios
con un senado renovado
hoy se dio inicio al abierto de tenis de
francia en roland garros de este año
será con pocos espectadores con
estrictas medidas de bioseguridad por
cuenta de los rebrotes de coronavirus
que se presentan en el país galo tenemos
reporte con nuestro enviado especial
muy buen día gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france24 blanco un gusto
saludarlos esta mañana de domingo
comenzamos este informativo con el
conflicto entre azerbaiyán y armenia en
europa oriental donde las últimas horas
se intensificaron los choques armados en
la frontera por el control del
territorio nagorno karabaj un enclave
separatista donde hoy se reportaron
civiles y militares muertos ante esta
situación
armenia decretó la ley marcial y una
movilización general armenia azerbaiyán
se encuentran en estado de guerra desde
1991 y si bien en tres años después
firmaron un alto el fuego vigente hasta
hoy se han denunciado violaciones de
esta tregua por ambas partes
estas movilizaciones en armenia y en
nagorno karabaj se producen después de
que el ministerio de defensa de
azerbaiyán lanzara hoy en contra una
contraofensiva en toda la línea
fronteriza en respuesta a los ataques
que asegura carmen y efectuó a primera
hora de la mañana contra posiciones
azerbaiyanas y también asentamientos
civiles rusia hace un llamado al alto
fuego y para entender un poco más
entonces lo que está ocurriendo en esa
parte del mundo
previamente conversamos con nuestro
corresponsal en moscú xavier colás quien
nos contó con qué apoyos cuenta cada
país y cuál es el papel que juega rusia
en este conflicto además de
conceptualizar nos el origen de este
conflicto
pues sí aunque se trata de un territorio
muy pequeño es verdad que por la zona en
la que está enclavado se trata de una
zona muy sensible y por tanto cuando
ahora mismo la preocupación no sólo en
esos dos países sino también en
importantes potencias militares que hay
alrededor hay que recordar que
azerbaiyán aunque es un país más pobre
cuenta con el apoyo de rusia que incluso
tiene en bases situadas en este
territorio
azerbaiyán por otro lado es un país que
tiene importantes reservas petrolíferas
lo cual le ha permitido llevar a cabo
una importante inversión en materia de
defensa hace tiempo que azerbaiyán
mantiene el deseo vivo de recuperar ese
territorio que para muchos azerbaiyanos
su ocupación por parte de armenia es una
herida en el orgullo nacional hay que
recordar que aunque rusia es el
principal apoyo de armenia está
vendiendo actualmente armas a ambos
países
amy cón y va a ver está nominada por el
presidente de donald trump para ocupar
la vacante que dejó la fallecida jueza
ruth báder ginsburg en la corte suprema
de eeuu la conservador es calificada
como la antítesis de la ex fuerza
progresista sin embargo durante la
nominación permitió reconocer su legado
por su parte el candidato demócrata de
bailén siguió insistiendo en que
el senado no debería tomar ninguna
decisión hasta que el país tenga un
nuevo presidente y nuevo congreso
andreas maya nos cuenta más en el
siguiente informe
la conservadora en miconi barrett es la
nominada del presidente de trump para la
corte suprema de justicia de eeuu
hoy es un honor para mí y nominar a una
de las mentes legales más brillantes y
talentosas de nuestra nación para la
corte suprema- 76 women es una mujer de
logros incomparables intelecto imponente
credenciales excelentes y lealtad
inquebrantable a la constitución de carl
station
la juez amy cón y vert
el líder republicano del senado mitch
mcconnell confirmó que habrá un voto
para decidir sobre su eventual
confirmación a pocos días de las
elecciones el candidato demócrata a la
presidencia joe biden expresó su
oposición las decisiones de la corte
suprema- afectan nuestra vida diaria y
la constitución fue diseñada para dar a
los votantes una voz sobre quién toma
esas decisiones el senado no debería
actuar hasta que el pueblo
estadounidense escoja a su próximo
presidente y el próximo congreso los
estadounidenses merecen ser escuchados
barrett es conocida por sus
inclinaciones ultra conservadoras y por
ser una ferviente católica muchos temen
que su llegada al máximo tribunal sea
sinónimo de un duro golpe para los
derechos al aborto en el país otros
celebran esa posibilidad
saben añadir women y les tenemos a otra
mujer en la corte suprema para ir en
contra de roe versus wade y dar más
decisiones de opciones a los estados me
apasiona mucho estoy muy emocionada de
ver lo que sucederá en el mundo mucho
está por cambiar con esta nueva nómina
si tienes una mujer que ha sido violada
o que cometió incesto y no quiere tener
el bebé para mí ese es su derecho dado
por dios
los demócratas denuncian que con barrett
también estaría en juego la continuidad
de la ley sanitaria conocida como
obamacare sin embargo al ser minoría en
el senado la bancada opositora no tiene
el poder para impedir la confirmación de
barber que inclinaría la balanza del
máximo tribunal durante décadas
belarús vivió otra jornada de
manifestaciones y nuevas oleadas de
detenciones más de 90 personas en su
mayoría mujeres el presidente francés
emmanuel macrón dijo que el presidente
bielorruso alexandr lukashenko debe irse
el ministro de asuntos exteriores de ese
país yo denuncio ante naciones unidas
criticando a las potencias occidentales
a gritos de svetlana presidenta así
iniciaron las manifestaciones de este
sábado en belarús desde hace casi dos
meses el país vive una manifestación
tras otra después de la discutida
reelección del presidente alexander
lukashenko al poder durante 26 años
contra el oponente
svetlana tica nos calla hoy refugiada en
lituania como en todas las protestas la
policía está deteniendo masivamente y
como todos los sábados las mujeres están
en el frente de la batalla en una
entrevista de manuel mckeown dijo que
estas mujeres imponen respeto el
presidente francés añade lo que pasa en
belarús es una crisis de poder un poder
autoritario que no logra aceptar la
lógica democrática y que se agarra con
fuerza
está claro que lukashenko tiene que
marcharse en naciones unidas donde sigue
la asamblea general
suecia expresó su temor a su insular o
desecho y suecia hasta la armada por la
situación en belarús tras las elecciones
del 9 de agosto que no fueron ni libres
ni justas ni del frío
en la misma tribuna belarús acusó a
occidente de injerencia y yo voy a este
año en realidad no son más que intentos
de sembrar el caos y la anarquía en
nuestro país para hacer que belarús
pierda muchos años de desarrollo de
varus y cuando llegó de más a emanuel
mccone viajará a letonia y lituania a
partir del lunes dos países europeos
fronterizos con belarús según el elíseo
no se excluye que se reúna con su vez la
nati cano calla
y seguimos con nuestro análisis diario
de lo que ocurre en la asamblea general
de naciones unidas porque justamente
ayer en el quinto día de esta asamblea
habló el canciller bielorruso quien
acusó a los países de occidente de y
dijo que quieren sembrar el caos y la
anarquía en su país para analizar el
tema quiero saludar en este momento a
antonella marte analista política y
directora del center for one en américa
en washington dice antonella la saludo
como carl a las declaraciones del
ministro de exteriores bielorruso para
los gobiernos de occidente buenos dias
raúl si efectivamente como bien lo
decías el ministro de exteriores de
bielorrusia habla de misma key denunció
este sábado en la asamblea general de
las naciones unidas esa imposición no de
sanciones contra el país que según él
perjudicaría claramente a todos no nos
olvidemos esto que es tan importante
bielorrusia vive está sumergida en una
crisis muy grave desde que comenzaron
todas estas masivas manifestaciones y
protestas ante el fraude electoral en
los comicios el régimen de lukashenko
claramente se vio obligado a esto bien
lo sabemos
a pedir el apoyo de rusia para poder
superar esta coyuntura y claramente ha
intensificado la persecución de
manifestantes opositores y periodistas
esto todas las últimas en las últimas
semanas pero claramente hay un fuerte
contraataque a los países occidentales
ahora antonella también hablaron los
primeros ministros del reino unido-
boris johnson y el de india narendra
modi que se enfocaron en la lucha contra
la pandemia de kobe 19 el desarrollo de
las vacunas contra esta enfermedad le
pregunto si hay más críticas que
respaldó a la onu en su rol en cuanto a
esta pandemia de coronavirus ver a raúl
yo creo que hay mucha más crítica que
otra cosa y esto no solamente en lo que
hemos visto la jornada de ayer sino a lo
largo de toda esta este aniversario de
las naciones unidas ayer el primer
ministro del reino unido- boris johnson
llamaba a la unión mundial para poder
hacer frente al coi 19 y dio
precisamente en la clave cuando dijo que
el comité unió a la humanidad como nunca
antes pero que la crisis generada se
volvió de alguna forma una fuerza de más
y dos potentes para fomentar la división
y creo que esto es a lo que hoy nos
estamos enfrentando boris johnson
aseguró que la noción de la comunidad
internacional estos conceptos que
teníamos tan claros para el siglo 21 que
al menos eso eso parecía están
completamente destrozadas y esas fueron
las palabras de boris johnson al menos
ayer y como no se puede continuar de
esta manera por lo que claramente el
sistema está hoy ante una crisis
existencial así como lo están las
naciones unidas al parecer de estas de
estas jornadas también recordemos bolt
johnson e hizo una fuerte crítica al
régimen comunista chino por por las
violaciones a las libertades en hong
kong y bueno las jornadas de este
aniversario número 75 de las naciones
unidas nos han mostrado en una buena
parte esta crisis existencial si se
puede decir dentro del organismo
internacional
así es antonella muchísimas gracias como
siempre que tenga usted un feliz día el
metro de santiago reabre de sus
estaciones que hace un año después del
estallido social en chile el país que
conoció entonces las mayores protestas
sociales de su historia desde el fin de
la dictadura de augusto pinochet dios
a parecer casi toda su red de metro
matías no tiene la noticia
la imagen de varias estaciones en llamas
la noche del 18 de octubre se convirtió
en la representación del descontento en
chile lo que empezó como unas protestas
estudiantiles con respecto a las tarifas
de pasajes terminó siendo una crisis
social a la cual se sumió el país en
semanas de violentas manifestaciones
callejeras casi un año después el metro
de santiago reabrió las puertas de todas
sus estaciones este viernes el proceso
de reconstrucción de las estaciones de
metro que duró aproximadamente 11 ms
recordemos que fueron 118 de 136
naciones que fueron destruidas de alguna
forma
y requirió una inversión final de 255
millones de dólares y requirió un
esfuerzo muy muy intenso de los
trabajadores de la empresa para los
usuarios la vuelta completa de
operaciones del ferrocarril
metropolitano es un alivio en una ciudad
en la que viven más de 71 millones de
personas
no acerca mucho más rápida toda la cita
santiago muy grande
el retrato facilita mucho a poco de
cumplirse un año la justicia aún no
aclara quién o quiénes quemaron el metro
de santiago el gobierno lo atribuyó
desde un principio a grupos criminales
organizados pero hasta ahora la
investigación judicial ha logrado
detener sólo a un puñado de personas
algunos pertenecientes a grupos de
barrasbravas quienes han relatado que
actuaron movidos por la efervescencia
social
atrás quedaron las largas filas de
espectadores y los estadios repletos en
el roland garros que comenzó hoy con una
llovizna constante y bajas temperaturas
el torneo se lleva a cabo en medio de un
resurgimiento de casos de kobe 19 en
francia y para saber los detalles de
cómo transcurre esta primera jornada
quiero saludar en ese momento a nuestra
enviada especial natalia ruiz
natalia delante
sí muy buenos días pues condiciones
climáticas bastante difíciles aquí en
parís tan solo 13 grados de temperatura
algo de lluvia pero sobre todo mucho
viento ya hay varios jugadores que
durante los encuentros han pedido
incluso a los árbitros que por favor
suspenda el partido porque de verdad que
han sido unas condiciones muy difíciles
sobre todo para aquellos que no están
jugando en la cancha principal que es el
philips a pie edificio que ustedes ven a
mis espaldas y que este año está
estrenando ese techo retráctil así que
por un lado es bueno porque allí pues al
menos podrán jugar resguardados de la
lluvia de este viento y sobre todo
podrán jugar hasta altas horas de la
noche algo que puede ser bastante
probable en vista de estas condiciones
climáticas y en caso de que los partidos
en las otras canchas pues se tengan que
ser aplazados o quizás comenzar con un
poco de tiempo de retraso en el día de
hoy ya hubo un primer golpe con la vida
de hugo para el belga número 11 de
cabeza de serie número 11 que ya fue
eliminado esta mañana ahora en este
momento está jugando la número 1 del
mundo
cabeza de serie número en el mundo
simona halep y bueno vamos a ver qué más
pasa en esta primera jornada de roland
garros
así es natalie por supuesto vamos a
estar muy pendientes entonces de cómo
transcurre y si al final se va a
suspender esto por las condiciones
climáticas o no muchísimas gracias a
ustedes también gracias por estar con
nosotros aquí en france 24
hasta la próxima
[Música]